From crushing wrestlers
in the ring
to crushing
box office records,
Dwayne Johnson
has spent the last 20 years
becoming
a blockbuster behemoth.
He now stars alongside
Ryan Reynolds and Gal Gadot
in Red Notice on Netflix.
This is my best friend.
-We're not friends.
-We're best friends.
But how did he get here?
Strap in,
put the pedal to the metal,
and prepare to speed
down his road to Netflix.
Dwayne Johnson's career
kicked off in 1996
under a less familiar name.
He stepped into
the WWF wrestling ring
as Rocky Maivia.
He was sweet and earnest,
but it was his reinvention
as wrestling heel "The Rock"
that would see him
become the face
of late-90s wrestling
and the master
of the catchphrase.
If you smell
what The Rock is cookin'!
Skip to 2019
and he'd play himself
in Fighting with My Family,
where he meets
Florence Pugh's
wannabe brawler Paige
and explains the secret
to his in-ring persona.
The Rock is me,
Dwayne Johnson,
just with the volume
turned way up,
the treble adjusted,
the base, same guy.
Wrestling popularity led
to his first acting work
in 1999,
where he appeared
in That '70s Show
playing his own father,
another famed wrestler,
Rocky Johnson.
You know, I got a son,
and one day,
he's going to become
the most electrifying man
in sports entertainment.
And in 2000, his wrestling
career went intergalactic
when he starred
in an episode
of Star Trek: Voyager.
Resistance is futile.
So is all your talk.
Dwayne's film career
kicked off in 2001,
where he sold his soul
for eternal life
as the Scorpion King
in The Mummy Returns.
You can put his head
on a CG scorpion's body,
but there's no
mistaking that attitude.
He impressed
producers so much
that an entire prequel
was built for the character,
giving Dwayne
his first leading role
in 2002's The Scorpion King,
a great showcase
for his physical abilities
and that world-famous
eyebrow.
And it gets so lonely.
In 2003,
he headed to the jungle
as bounty hunter Beck
in The Rundown.
Cementing him as the action
star of the moment,
he even got
an in-film endorsement
from another
action film legend.
Have fun.
Based on 2004's
Walking Tall,
Arnie passed the torch
to the right guy,
as Dwayne took down
a crooked casino,
armed only with a big stick.
Then, he was off to Mars
as Sarge in 2005's Doom,
an adaptation
of the popular video game
and a rare villainous role
for our star.
Good luck with that,
Karl Urban.
2005 also let Dwayne
flex his dramatic muscles
in Be Cool.
He also got to show off
some very groovy trousers.
Scorchin'!
And 2006 saw him stepping
into the dystopian world
of Southland Tales
as amnesiac action star
Boxer Santaros.
In the late 2000s, we saw
more of Dwayne's funny side,
from putting himself in
the hands of Hannah Montana
to squaring off against
funnyman Steve Carell
in Get Smart.
His role as Agent 23
in the 2008 comedy
was the first time
he was credited
as Dwayne Johnson
instead of The Rock.
Though he still had
that classic Rock style.
Thank you.
The laughs kept on coming
when, in 2009,
he hosted
Saturday Night Live
for the third time.
And later that year,
he turned up
in Family Guy as himself
to help censor
a raunchy love scene.
Wow.
Oh, and he played
the tooth fairy
in 2010's Tooth Fairy.
If this guy turned up
in your room at night,
you'd hand him
your entire gob,
no questions asked.
And who could forget
his turn alongside
Samuel L. Jackson
in 2010's The Other Guys
as the cocky and very
short-lived detective
Christopher Danson.
Luckily, Dwayne's
next character
lasted a bit longer,
the SS agent and bounty
hunter extraordinaire
Lucas Hobbs.
Above all else,
we don't ever,
ever let them
get in the cars.
Chasing down the wrongfully
accused Dominic Toretto
in 2011's Fast Five
was Johnson's ticket to
the blockbuster big leagues.
The film took over $600
million at the box office
and established Hobbs
as a vital piece
of the Fast and Furious
universe.
Hobbs would return
four more times.
In Fast & Furious 6,
he worked alongside
his one-time nemesis, Dom,
to bring down Luke Evans'
dastardly Owen Shaw…
in turn,
earning him the wrath
of Jason Statham's
Deckard Shaw
in Furious 7.
By the time we reach
The Fate of the Furious
in 2017,
Hobbs was steering missiles
by hand.
Is there anything
this guy can't do?
Well, apart from get on
with Jason Statham,
as proved
by their hilarious team-up
in 2019's Hobbs and Shaw.
Expect more banter
from these two
as a sequel is in the works.
While Dwayne spent
the last decade
destroying an entire car
festival's worth of motors,
he built himself into
the ultimate leading man.
In 2013, he went
from fast and furious
to be vast and furious
when he played a bodybuilder
turned kidnapper
in Pain & Gain.
Then, in 2014,
he played the man, the myth,
the legend, Hercules…
before returning
to modern day in 2015
in San Andreas,
where he battled the largest
earthquake in history
as helicopter rescue pilot
Ray Gaines.
Shit.
Dwayne and San Andreas
director Brad Peyton
had so much fun
wrecking a city,
they teamed up
to destroy another one
in 2018's Rampage.
In 2015, Dwayne took on
the biggest TV role
of his career
as Spencer Strasmore,
a retired NFL player turned
player-manager in Ballers.
Think of it as
an NFL version of Entourage,
with Johnson
on highly charismatic form
over its five seasons.
We got to hear
Dwayne's more tuneful side
in 2016's Moana,
where he guided
the film's heroine
as shapeshifting
demigod Maui.
Sticking with the beach,
but less family-friendly,
is 2017's Baywatch,
a raunchy take
on the 90s TV classic,
where Dwayne played head
lifeguard Mitch Buchannon.
In 2017's Jumanji:
Welcome to the Jungle,
Dwayne continued to stretch
his comedy muscles
and his actual muscles…
as the smouldering
Dr Xander Bravestone,
a video game action hero
possessed by the soul
of a neurotic
high school student
Do you have control of that
or does that just
happen naturally?
It just happens naturally.
A role so good, he repeated
the trick two years later
in Jumanji: The Next Level,
where, this time,
he channelled the spirit
of Danny DeVito.
Those are words
I never expected to say.
Oh, my joints
feel like butter.
Cementing
his action-hero credentials,
Dwayne gave us
his own version of Die Hard
in 2018's Skyscraper,
where he played
a one-legged veteran
saving his family from the
world's tallest building.
Don't eat your dinner
during the jumping scene.
If watching Dwayne Johnson's
Road to Netflix
has left you wanting more
of his life story,
you could check out
2021's Young Rock,
a sitcom based
on his teenage years
that jumps
between his school days
and early football career,
and his life living
amongst wrestling legends.
Which brings us
all the way to 2021
and Dwayne's first
Netflix Original movie,
Red Notice.
If our trip through his
career taught us anything,
it's that
he's just as comfortable
wisecracking
as cracking skulls.
And here he gets to do both
as FBI agent John Hartley.
Tasked with bringing in
jewel thief Ryan Reynolds,
he soon finds himself
working with
his former nemesis
to bring down an even bigger
thief played by Gal Gadot.
Arrest me.
Make sure
you don't miss Red Notice,
now streaming on Netflix,
and to hear how more
of your favourite stars
took their road to Netflix,
make sure you subscribe
to the channel.